now we already know that david tennant
is going to be returning in the 60th
anniversary of doctor who but will we be
seeing matt smith and peter capaldi
let's discuss welcome to sidetrack your
sci-fi tv
and movie channel
[Music]
now i'm not going to pretend to know for
a fact that matt smith and peter capaldi
are coming back to doctor who this is
purely just speculation and something
that i would absolutely love as a fan we
already know that david tennant is
coming back alongside catherine tate
bernard cribbins and basically the
entire cast of season 4 of doctor who
but as this is such a monumentous
achievement for any science tv show 60
years of television as well as
coinciding with the bbc's 100 year
anniversary i feel like they're going to
do something
way bigger from set leaks we've already
seen that david tennant and catherine
tate are back and joining them looks to
be neil patrick harris playing the
celestial toy maker now the celestial
toy maker hasn't been on our screen
since
1966 way over 50 years but last time we
saw him the doctor said that they would
definitely meet each other again because
the games aren't over and that's why i
along with many other people who have
been speculating about doctor who have
come to the conclusion of
the celestial toymaker is going to mess
with the doctor's regenerations turning
him back into the 10th doctor david
tennant which then means that david 10
is technically 10 and 14 unless they do
some weird timing why be wibbly wobbly
stuff and then my theory is that they'll
also then regenerate into matt smith and
then peter capaldi so then he can
regenerate back into jody whitaker he
will then regenerate into shuji gagawa
who will then lead this series in 2024.
why do i want this so badly why do i
want matt smith and peter capaldi to
come back well the answer is very simple
i became a fan of doctor who in 2005 and
when the revival hit christopher
frackerson was my first doctor
therefore he is also one of my favorite
doctors just because he's my first he's
what got me into the franchise now after
christopher xton left and regenerated
into david tennant i got my first taste
of regeneration and fell in love with
david tennant's incarnation as the
doctor along with everyone else in the
country who absolutely adores david
tennant as the doctor i loved matt smith
i love peter capaldi as well and i would
love to see them both come back now i
would absolutely love it as well if
christopher exton came back however i
can't see that happening he has
mentioned that he's going to be doing
something for the 60th anniversary but
it's more likely to be something for the
audio books from big finish just think
how amazing it would be if david tennant
came back who then
worked with matt smith and peter capaldi
and probably working with jody whitaker
as well who would then finally meet
shooty gatwa making a five doctor story
ah
that would be absolutely
amazing if we see matt smith come back
as well i also hope that we're going to
be seeing karen gillan and after
darville as amy and rory and of course
if peter capote is coming back we need
to see clara now this is a pretty short
video i know but i want to know your
opinions
what do you think is going to happen in
the 60th anniversary what are your hopes
what do you want to happen and who do
you want to see return do you agree with
me do you want to see matt smith and
peter capalli along with their companion
to return and potentially christopher
eccleston or are you happy just having
david tennant and catherine tate
let me know in the comment section down
below thank you so much for watching and
i'll see you in another video
[Music]
you